think it's a miracle of faith and
resolution Israel because of the
resolution the resolve of its citizens
The Genius of its people has become the
Juggernaut uh Innovation nation in the
world and we have uh we've just crossed
in GDP we've crossed Japan
France Britain
um
and Germany GDP per capita and remember
when I I described this in my book when
we began the economic Revolution uh
towards free markets away from socialism
we were basically the last place in
Western Europe and now we're pretty much
in first place and we're we're going to
catch up with the United States that's
a personal Quest I'm not saying that
since but we'll catch up with the United
States
I'm Dave Rubin and joining me today is
the twice and future Prime Minister of
the state of Israel and author of the
new book Bibi my story prime minister
Benjamin Netanyahu welcome to the Reuben
report
good to be with you please you know I
have to say I've I've watched you
obviously on television a million
interviews over the years speaking at
the UN all kinds of things and one of
the things that I always think when
you're speaking or any advocate for
Israel is why don't they show more maps
just show a map of the Middle East and
the size of Israel versus you know the
entire region and everything else and
then I get a copy of your book and we're
going to show you the full thing on
screen but I'm going to hold it up for
just a moment that's exactly how the
book begins right the opening flap right
there just to give a little context to
the size and I thought that would be an
interesting way to uh start the
conversation wait a minute you have to
do something open that book yes
um put your finger on Israel so they get
a feeling for the Arab world this is
Israel right yes exactly yeah and and
don't even begin to Encompass the Arab
world or Iran in this in these two flaps
so that's that's my two cents worth of a
proportion yeah well I thought it was a
nice way to start because basically when
people look at most maps of the world
you you can't even fit one letter of the
word Israel on Israel itself and I feel
like if people understood that a little
bit more maybe they'd be perhaps a
little bit Kinder is that just naivete
as someone that's been defending Israel
for you know 60 plus years well it's a
social thinking but yeah I guess when
people are exposed to the facts which
many are not uh yeah they see it
differently and they they realize that
Israel is a tiny country
but it's a gigantic country because even
though we constitute uh less than one
tenth one-tenth of one percent of the
world's population we have been
consistently ranked in the decade uh
that I led the country between 2010 and
220 uh as the eighth most powerful uh uh
country in the world which is uh it's
kind of unbelievable I mean when you
think of it uh and that that is I
suppose not only you can explain that
rationally but I think it's a miracle of
faith and resolution Israel because of
the resolution the resolve of its
citizens a genius of its people has
become the Juggernaut uh Innovation
nation in the world and we have uh we've
just crossed in GDP we've crossed Japan
France Britain
um
and Germany GDP per capita and remember
when I I described this in my book when
we began the economic Revolution uh
towards free markets away from socialism
we were basically the last place in
Western Europe and now we're pretty much
in first place and we're we're going to
catch up with the United States that's
a personal Quest I'm not saying that
since but we'll catch up with the United
States
so as I described in the opening you are
the twice and future Prime Minister of
Israel as as we speak right now you're
in the midst of of forming this
Coalition you have the mandate to do it
you've done this a couple times before
but Israel seems to have elections every
what six months or so uh are you
confident that you're gonna pull this
thing together I mean this one looks a
little more solid I guess than the last
few right
yeah well we had first of all this is a
sixth time I'm forming a government and
uh I've been Israel's longest serving
prime minister and I describe my
travails and triumphs in the in the
course of that very long career within a
year I'll be the longest serving elected
leader of a democracy in over half a
century of any place in the world but
somebody put me on node the other day
give me a note and he said well you
should know that there are leaders
who've come back from political death
church one example it's not God being
Invisibles but this fellow told me I've
checked when was the last time somebody
came back from political death twice and
he said that happened three quarters of
a century ago so I don't uh I don't
belittle the task before me but I think
after a succession of uh un indecisive
elections uh in the formation of a
peculiar government that was brought
down after a year we now have a solid
majority of coherent majority who form a
center right and right government
coherent in policy that will I think
take Israel and the Middle East to
Fantastic places contrary to the
left-leaning Press will get more peace
treaties
perhaps and the Arab Israeli conflict
altogether not the palestinian-israeli
conflict the conflict of the Arab world
which is 99 times the size of the
Palestinians and block Iran and develop
technologies that will stupefy the world
and service all of all of humanity these
are some of the goals that I have and I
think that Within Reach I guess I think
it'll be more stable and I think it'll
be successful you mentioned a center
right or right Coalition can you sort of
compare how that's different than say an
American right I know you're a student
of American politics as well but for you
guys the right is it's a little bit
different just by the nature of the the
demographics and everything else
well I think the uh first of all it's a
parliamentary system so you have to
Cobble together a coalition it's not as
if the prime minister is elected by the
popular vote like the president he can
choose his cabinet and so on this is not
do you get jealous of our two-party
system when you're in the midst of
trying to Cobble this thing together
they're wildly so envious to the roots
of my being but because cobbling
together Coalition is like uh you know
you're familiar with the Rubik's Cube
you know yeah of course turn one and
then it you have to turn the other one
and it matches and you turn it and you
think you got it and then the last piece
doesn't match you have to start all over
again that's more or less what I've been
doing over the last few weeks but I
think I think I'm getting there I'm this
is not Reuben's Cube this is Rubik's
Cube I'm Rubik so at the end I have to
be rubric or there's no government uh
there will be a government uh so uh the
first thing is you have to Cobble
together a coalition uh that is a
majority in the the members of the
parliament our Congress if you will and
they choose the Prime Minister and
obviously if we put it together they'll
they'll choose me that's the first uh
change the Second Chance is because you
have a multi multiplicity of parties you
don't have two parties you have I don't
know 12 parties in the knesset something
like that uh and uh the third thing is
that
um the right in Israel
is first of all premised the differences
between left and right our premise first
of all in the intensity that you put on
the question of security security is the
number one issue in Israeli elections
the economy is a second uh
sometimes a distance second uh and the
uh I would say the uh intensity of
identification with the Jewish State
and how you protect it is really what
guides uh God's Israeli elections and
that's what brought me to the office
here because the outgoing government to
Cobble together their coalition
uh basically made a pact with uh a party
and our party that
identifies with the Muslim Brotherhood
the Muslim brother
to recognize that Jewish State and wants
to dissolve a Jewish State now obviously
the outgoing Coalition didn't want to
dissolve the Jewish state but they made
themselves Hostage to uh a party that
does in order to stay in Paro that
didn't last long and it was brought down
and now uh I assure you that's not going
to be repeated by the way many Arabs
support me many abs vote for the likud
and Arabs have served in the liquid and
conserve in any government in the future
but the the issue is not the ethnicity
of the the voters or the ministers or
the president members it's their
ideology and once the ideology to which
unfortunately some Jews subscribe to
Jewish knesset members that Israel
should be dissolved destroyed eliminated
uh obviously that didn't do well with
the voters so here we are we have uh we
have a way to correct this if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about international issues
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our International playlist and if you
want to watch full interviews on a
variety of topics check out our full
episode playlist they're all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification Bell